two men in California exposed one of the
largest cases of fraud in the history of
the state more than 950 million dollars
bill Reynolds and mark sir Sam seed
discovered doctors were being paid to
perform what some say were unnecessary
spinal fusion surgeries the scam
involved doctors allegedly implanting
counterfeit hardware into hundreds of
patients Judge former police officer and
host of the CBS series whistleblower
Alex Ferrara spoke to the two men and
patients left with devastating
consequences coming up guys these are
the whistleblowers nearly a decade after
bill Reynolds and mark sir since he
first learned about one of the most
outrageous medical frauds in California
history
they met with some of the patients still
suffering from the devastating
consequences of this scam after surgery
it was nothing but pain filled days I
can sit I couldn't walk I couldn't be a
parent I didn't want to leave anymore
you know I one time I I was planning I'm
gonna go outside and I'm gonna run
together they would discover an illegal
scheme where middlemen were paid to find
patients who had back problems stemming
from work-related injuries and doctors
were paid kickbacks to perform the
spinal surgeries at specific hospitals
one of the physicians wanted Super Bowl
tickets airfare and hotel the scam left
many patients in unbearable pain from
surgeries some say they didn't need in
the first place this was entirely a
medically unnecessary surgery that was
performed ultimately they would learn
that hospitals were not only over
billing for the spinal Hardware I'm
looking at invoices that ranged anywhere
from three hundred fifty to four hundred
and seventy five thousand but in many
instances dangerous counterfeit hardware
was implanted into the backs of innocent
people we've had experts come out that
identified my screws as being
counterfeit screws counterfeit screws
like this one quickly got mixed in with
FDA approved screws like this one made
by a reputable medical device company
from South Korea those screws go into
patients bones little pieces of those
threads can break off in people's bodies
and end up in their tissue it can cause
serious complications the pain is
traveled up to my neck to my shoulders
I'm positive it is because of the
counterfeit hardware that was placed in
my back do you think your doctor knew
that the hardware was counterfeit
absolutely everyone you said that yes
without hesitation why do you think that
greed money it's important to blow the
whistle on this somebody has to step
forward and bring the attention to the
magnitude of this problem Alex Ferrer is
with us now Alex good morning here's a
question I never thought I'd be asking
what are the repercussions of having
counterfeit screws in your back well as
you saw Derek imposes on the piece she
suffered excruciating she still suffers
Tuesday excruciating pain she had
infections for years until the screws
were taken out of her back and
determined that three out of the four
were counterfeit typically those screws
do not come out once they're in bone
grows over them and they're there to
stay the the the other patient we one of
the other patients we interviewed mary
bravo is in unbearable pain
she actually collapsed during our
interview it the the repercussions of
these screws being in your body is is
just so dramatic because being older not
letting material they're not medical
grade titanium yeah so they can leach
toxins into your blood and they also can
break pieces off into your tissue and
the worst part about it is they made ten
thousand counterfeit screws and mix them
in surgical trays with real screws there
is no way for us to know who's walking
around with surgical how many and
there's no way to tell how many or who
they are or they're in how many people
were involved in this game Alex well the
scam was much bigger than than just the
part we're reporting I mean we're
reporting about what happened in
California and it involved the the owner
of the owner of a hospital Pacific
Hospital of Long Beach in California
who's now doing five years in prison and
is or
to pay back ten million dollars
middlemen who were hired to pay
kickbacks to doctors and kickbacks the
people who brought him patients for the
back surgeries and the doctors knew what
they were doing doctors who were getting
kickbacks for performing surgeries some
of which people say we're completely
unnecessary there's a question about
whether doctors knew that the surgical
screws were counterfeit the federal
criminal investigation that's been going
on focused on the kickbacks not on the
on the whether they were counterfeit or
not there's a pending whistleblower suit
that's been stayed but this was all part
of a larger nationwide healthcare fraud
investigation the part we're reporting
was a scam of about a billion dollars
and that's money that taxpayers pay the
nationwide one is two billion dollars he
might not have known if the screws were
counterfeit but they certainly knew that
they didn't necessarily have to do the
surgery that they were doing and those
about a hundred so patients suing them
right now those are the ones who feel
they know that they were victimized
there's so many there's no way to know I
was gonna ask how many people what
happened to the people involved in the
crime
do you know that well there's about a
hundred and sixty five doctors in the
nationwide scheme that have been
indicted as well as nurses an attorney
and it's a very broad investigation but
our part is is that we're reporting is
limited really to most of California
alright thank you it's good to see you
we appreciate it always hard to hear the
stories but good to see your face thank
you she it's great to be here you can
watch whistleblowers the billion dollar
back surgery scam patients in pain and
peril that's tonight at 8:00 7:00
central here on CBS